,
match numéro deux.
- On suit tout ça. Merci
beaucoup Jean-François.
♪ C'est une poupée
Qui fait : non, non, non, non ♪
♪ Toute la journée
Elle fait : non, non, non, non ♪
Il y a de ces chansons
qui marquent nos étés
et depuis longtemps.
Ce soir, on retourne
loin en arrière : 1966,
c'est l'année où tout le monde
chantait le même refrain.
"La poupée qui fait non",
adaptée au Québec
par les Sultans.
Louis Philippe Ouimet.
- ♪ C'est une poupée
qui fait non, non, non, non ♪
- 55 ans plus tard, est-ce
qu'on vous parle encore
de La poupée qui fait non?
BRUCE HUARD,
chanteur, Les Sultans
- Bien oui! Bien oui, c'est une
étiquette, ça. Tu vas au cinéma
avec ta blonde et tu les entends
chuchoter en arrière, tu sais :
"Hé, c'est... je pense que c'est
le chanteur des Sultans, ça."
♪ Pourtant,
je donnerais ma vie ♪
- À l'été 1966, pourquoi
vous avez décidé d'interpréter
La poupée qui fait non,
de Michel Polnareff?
Parce que ce n'est pas
une chanson des Sultans.
- Oui, c'était une idée
du producteur,
de la compagnie de disque.
♪ Toute la journée,
elle fait non, non, non ♪
- Est-ce que vous l'aimiez,
cette chanson-là?
- Ah, on ne voulait pas
que ça sorte pantoute!
(rires)
- Pourquoi?
- Mais dans le fond, c'est ça
qui nous a mis au monde.
Tu sais, s'il y a de quoi qu'on
peut remercier la compagnie
de disques, c'est ça
qui nous a mis sur la map.
♪ Pourtant,
je donnerais ma vie ♪
- Parce que ça jouait
tout le temps à la radio.
- Ah, c'était incroyable!
C'était vraiment un super hit.
Je l'ai même entendue à CHOM
à un moment donné, j'étais...
j'étais "floored", comme on dit,
tu sais. J'ai dit : "Wow!"
Non, elle était hot. La toune
était vraiment... Tu sais,
je sais pas, ça a soulevé
un intérêt généralisé.
♪ Elles croient qu'elles ont
sur nous l'avantage ♪
Les journaux disaient
qu'on était le groupe le plus
populaire des années... en 1966.
De tous les groupes qu'il
y avait, c'est ce que
les journaux disaient.
- Une partie du succès des
Sultans, c'est que Bruce Huard
était pas mal beau bonhomme.
- Je pense que c'était ça,
l'idée du producteur. C'était
d'associer, mettons, une chanson
cute, bien le fun, avec des
"Beau Brummel", tu sais, ce qui
va faire en sorte que les filles
vont connecter. Je pense
que c'est ça. Et c'est
tout le monde qui a connecté.
♪ Elle est vraiment jolie ♪
♪ Que j'en rêve la nuit ♪
- 55 ans plus tard, êtes-vous
encore capables de chanter
La poupée qui fait non?
- Ah, on peut essayer.
- On essaie?
- Même s'il est 11 h le matin.
- J'ai apporté ma guitare, OK.
Attention, il va y avoir
quelques fausses notes.
C'est parti!
♪ C'est une poupée
qui fait non, non, non, non ♪
♪ Toute la journée,
elle fait non, non, non, non ♪
♪ Elle est,
elle est vraiment jolie ♪
- Vous avez passé le test!
(rires)
Merci beaucoup.